he's going to the AFC Championship game
after taking care of business yesterday
against one of his former teams he is
none other than one of the top in the
game and no doubt fired up for LSU
football tonight he's tiring Matthew the
Kansas City Chiefs how are you tiring it
has been a minute let's get into it from
from this weekend first things first up
what in the world was it like on that
sideline down 24 nothing you know
another glass football awhile now and
you know it was surprising that you know
we weren't flustered like in our mind we
weren't out of the game we just needed a
tester you know really make the next
play and you know we were able to do
that so uh we really didn't start the
right way but we'll respond it you know
the right way why I guess that's yeah
you can never prepare for that though
right
I've never seen anything like it I've
never seen anything like the game that
you played
that's why people love sports you know
uh it's not scripted anything can happen
and you know you know we were really
lucky obviously to obviously be at home
in front of our crowd so uh you know in
our minds like I said I know we felt
like we just needed to make one plate
and you know we made that play and then
obviously a couple other plays when our
favor and you know uh you know Pat
mahomes took off from there
you sure did he sure did I guess what if
you could peg a play maybe Hardman's
return after 24 nothing or what we're
talking about and the media quite a bit
was Bill O'Brien's decision to kick a
field goal on fourth and hardly an inch
to to go up 24 nothing as opposed to
maybe go for what I guess we can't call
it a kill shot since your team put up 50
were you surprised that he went for the
field goal there defensively tiring oh
you know in my mind you know I thought
they were going to go for it but you
know
I don't really know really what happened
you know but I think ultimately um you
know those through special team plays
that we made obviously the you know
Hardman getting at that long return and
you know dad coming down and forcing a
fumble and you know even dad on Park on
the punt team making that tackle to stop
them on a fourth down I thought those
three plays really sparked the team and
know the deeper you get the season I
think special teams become much bigger
and obviously our special attendance
definitely stepped up really when we
needed it the most tiring Matthew here
on the Rich Eisen show again you've been
around some really special offensive
players in your day Tyron obviously from
Arizona being around Fitz being around
others being around in Houston deshaun
Watson what in the world is it like
being around Patric mahomes you know
he's always one of the first guys in the
building you know he's so into his team
right like he loved his team he loved
his guys he loved his linemen he loved
everybody in the building man and you
know to kind of have that you know at
the quarterback position um you know a
god that's you know well-liked
throughout the building throughout the
locker room especially well he's a team
player man and I thought last night
yesterday you know he reminded the world
you know why he's the best player in the
NFL and you know I joke with him after
the game you know I don't know who made
him mad you know maybe people are
talking about him enough this season but
you know he was electric jacks today I'm
he was everything you know that we want
um and you know obviously we don't
expect them to score every every
possession you know he says we we do
have high expectations for Patton he
always comes through and um he knows
good to see yesterday yeah I mean let's
be honest again seven straight touchdown
drives that's never happened before in
the history of the postseason and we may
never see it well here's how we we may
see it again but I don't think we'll
ever see it again by a team that's down
24 nothing to start the game at home
never see that again that's nuts it's
crazy I guess it could you could also
say it all started with with Hartman
showing up like LL Cool J did you see
that his arrival at Mimi cool actually
uh ate breakfast that morning okay
before the game so I saw a whole
wardrobe yeah he had the big gold box
speaker so breakfast he brought it to
breakfast - yeah you know we got a lot
of personality on our team and I think
the whole world kind of saw that
yesterday you know we when we showed up
to play ok so just again walk me through
this you're sitting there for breakfast
he walks in as LL Cool J with the boom
box yeah and you had no idea he was
doing it that's how you learned of it
that he was doing it he's been one of
those guys you know kind of you know
making those kind of he's making it fun
you know walking into the stadium a
couple weeks ago he wore my Jersey
you know so he's having fun with it he's
enjoying it and um you know that's what
you want from from your teammates you
want them to have fun you want them to
be relaxed you know so they can go out
there and you know have a good game
turn Matthew here on the Rich Eisen show
and let's talk about the the defensive
unit because that's been what a lot of
people in my part of the world and the
paparazzi have given Kansas City a lot
more credence as a Super Bowl contender
not mahomes we can all assume about the
offense it's the way you and your
defensive mates have stiffened up
tightened up over the last several weeks
what has happened to cause you guys to
gel with the spagnolo coordinated
defense as you have yeah you know you
know I think you know even going back to
the spring rich and you know obviously
even earlier in the season uh you know I
think I thought the whole time we was
just chasing improvement right like we
was just trying to get better and you
know guys weren't necessarily you know
nitpicking
one another we was just trying to get it
right and it was a new system for uh and
the details were new and I think you
know you gotta get to know your coaches
they have to get to know their players
and um you know I thought we did that at
the right time then uh you know I
thought Spags I think he's doing a great
job just being very detailed and you
know what he wants done um you know he
has a great staff as well that really
puts a lot of information in front of us
so we're able to kind of digest it
throughout the weekend you know we've
been we've just been trying to stay
committed to one another and I think
really that's good helping us train much
faster we're communicating much better
and uh you know that's what it's all
about you know especially going to a
playoff well now going into the AFC
Championship game and you have placed in
front of you or coming downhill at you
quite the challenge I mentioned how the
defense is tightening up here comes the
Titans who have tightened up in their
way with Derrick Henry
I mean Earl Thomas who I believe is
going in the Hall one day said that he
saw the Patriots film and noticed the
Patriots had no interest in tackling him
and that the Ravens were gonna take a
different approach and I don't know if
you saw in one particular instance Henry
gave him not one but two stiff arms on a
run Saturday night in eliminating
Baltimore I wonder what you have in mind
with Derrick Henry coming your way this
weekend tyrant you know it's a whole lot
of respect for first and foremost uh I
think what he's doing for his football
team is you know Jim Brown like you know
what I mean to kind of put it into
perspective but you know rich I feel
like we're tested right like we're
prepared man if you look at the guys we
faced all season
we've been playing top running backs you
know Josh Jacobsen Dalvin cook and
Leonard fournette so Derrick Henry
earlier in the season and so we've been
in front of good running backs right
downhill running backs and I think in
our minds you know we're tested but
obviously I'm it's gonna be a tough
challenge you know trying to tackle you
know the Russian King no doubt
um Andy Reid you know as I've been
saying here it is a family show so I
cleaned it up he does appear that he's
out of F's to give he's run out of him
he look he's he's at the he's in a part
of his career where he's made several
championship games before obviously last
year - now this one again what is it
what is it like being around him
Tyron yeah yeah I mean you know Coach
really is such a great coach right he's
all about King he's all about family and
really he's all about being one and you
know I think we have a coach like that
you know a lot of expected you know from
his players he puts a lot on us you know
as expected and I think in our minds and
this locker room this year it's all
about trying to win it you know for Andy
Reed you know he's done a lot for the
game of football
you know he's done a lot for a lot of
guys you know throughout this league a
lot of coaches in the league and you
know in our minds it's it's time so um
you know we definitely have to deliver
format you can really go out there and
and play hard play hard form and in
terms of turning down hits you know
obviously you won't with Henry or at
least your teammates plan not to you
turn one down under Shaun Watson towards
the end of the game yesterday tire and
that got caught on on Twitter your
response in my mind was quite something
why did you not take deshaun Watson out
when you had towards the end of the game
I give me the floor on that yeah I mean
rich you know like I said on Twitter man
the game was over right and you know
I've never been that kind of player you
know always felt like I was one of the
toughest guys on the field and I didn't
need to kind of I didn't need to take a
cheap shot I didn't need to take a free
lick at a guy um you know especially a
young guy a superstar a guy that this
league needs it's all about respect
you know I was I was raised by guys like
Patrick Peters and a Larry Fitzgerald
and no matter if it wasn't allusion is
about the respect that a game and about
the respect for the guys across
you and home you know that that's really
just how I play and what I try to you
know really showed up that the guys you
know behind me and a younger generation
did did Watson say thank you or what
what's what happens when that happens
cuz he must have known yeah what you did
obviously we well we joked about it
after the game and you know we were kind
of talking as he was getting on a bus
getting ready to leave and you know he
told me he loved me you know obviously
and you know I just told him and I'll
keep going you know you know a lot is
expected of you and you know you're a
good guy man you good for this league
and he kind of you know punch me in the
stomach I said appreciate you not
hitting me on that place that is amazing
that's great and last one for you is
part of that because you knew your LSU
Tigers we're gonna take care of Clemson
tonight is that you know I think the
stage is set man for the Tigers uh you
know what what a year they've had and um
you know I think the be crowned king you
have to beat the king right and I think
Clemson is that team you know they've
been to the championship game you know
really I think two times in the last
four years so that program is
outstanding and um I think the kind of
top of our year you know you know why
not play you know the other teams that
you know so called so called themselves
on a death valley you know so hopefully
we can handle business but a not
believing about Tigers I believe in
coach oh I think burrows going to show
up I think they'll pit and you know
think Leigh's gonna have a great game
and uh well I mean you know it's
interesting obviously your Stricker your
circumstances there and your journey
they're totally different however you
were you made yourself you were
self-made individual Tyron the old honey
badger back in the day and just seeing
just seeing what burrows made of himself
Edwards a lair what he has made of
himself just a whole bunch of those kids
and I know it's tough to say well these
are self-made kids at a crown jewel
campus and program like LSU but I'm
wondering if you see any connective
tissue here between you and what your
you're watching right now yeah man I
think I think this team represents a lot
of the guys that have came through those
doors before you know guys like myself
and you know Adele Beckham and Jarvis
Landry you know Jamal Adam so I think
this team just has that spirit land you
know like they believe they're so
confident you know they got some great
leaders some great seniors some great
Julius and uh you know they got a damn
good quarterback right so I think it's
all working out for don't forget Patrick
I don't want you get you in trouble
don't forget Patrick Peterson don't
forget p2 there now right right right
I don't want to get you in trouble hey
Tyree you take care of yourself I always
love chatting with you your your journey
is something that I'm always rooting for
as you know and to see you in an AFC
championship game and perhaps down in
South Florida in a couple weeks that
would be quite something
right back at you will speak soon that's
Tyrann Mathieu at Matthew underscore era
the kingdom landlord right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app